hi it's finals week and boy am i feeling
stressed
maybe it's because i'm a procrastinator
but it always seems like when i have the
most work to do the world decides to
become the most fascinating so
in lieu of regular book content here's a
video about things that have interested
me this week
aliens especially these three videos
apparently recorded by us pilots off the
coast of mexico in 2004 just this year
these videos have been confirmed by the
military as
ufos apparently one of them moved like
this above the water
let me knows video about these
pill-shaped objects is amazing
speaking of aliens venus venera probes
did you know we have actual pictures
taken on the surface of venus yeah
while the us was busy hooking up with
mars the soviet union was all like
who needs you guys venus is the best
planet ever except it wasn't
mainly because every probe they sent to
the surface survived for about an hour
before being melted by the planet's
hellish temperature and pressure
the fact that we have any photographs of
the surface is fascinating though
nothing is as fascinating as the english
royals
what a weird bunch of people i never
really paid much attention to these
lunatics until this week when i went
down the rabbit hole
basically the queen is immortal because
she doesn't want charles to be king
because he [ __ ] up his marriage with
diana because
he loved this woman now diana is dead
and no one likes charles and one of his
sons harry
married an actress and now they aren't
royal kinda but they still are
very confusing stuff and the queen is
still alive
you know who wasn't english jack london
he was as american and as manly as they
come
whatever that means author of call of
the wild white fang and the sea wolf was
actually a socialist and not just
casually his work of dystopian fiction
the iron heel foresaw
a global oligarchy controlling the
planet and the socialist forces plotting
its demise
guess who's going to do a review of that
book soon not paul mccartney who i've
been listening to constantly all week
his new album comes out this month
called mccartney 3 which like its
predecessors were written produced
and performed by the man himself that's
how you get a masterpiece like this
last but not least is this not the most
eerie incomprehensible video you've ever
seen
yeah that that gave me nightmares
anyways those are the things i liked
this week
like and subscribe if you enjoy and let
me know in the comments what's
interesting you this week